yesterday i came to ireland from scratch
and we secured a rent-to-rent property
investment
which will be giving david about 500
pounds per month
[Laughter]
today we need to somehow raise the 1300
pounds
investment that's needed to actually get
the keys for the rent to rent property
we could pay tomorrow couldn't we
we decided the best way to make some
quick money from scratch
was to go to belfast and find some
property investments
which we could then attempt to package
and sell to some property investors
that's not that easy but we needed the
money and we needed it
now
say before i was unemployed i sexy drive
that
[ __ ] there so thank god oh my god
like how crap is that i don't know it
looks fun to me this is a trick it's so
crap
is it is it all day getting wet
would you ever go back to it never i
don't know
right you're right there
here in belfast so um okay it's gonna be
nine o'clock in about two minutes time
so
why don't we make some calls and
wait for some stages to open okay you
look a bit lost
you look like a lost puppy just not sure
where to go dave is getting a cup of
coffee
we just arrived in belfast the guy who's
serving david the coffee
knows a man in this street who's got a
house that he wants to sell apparently
it's not on the market
it needs a lot of work so it could be a
property we could buy refurbish
refinance obviously we're not going to
buy it we'll pass it to an investor
david is trying to get the name and the
number of the seller
from the coffee shop man so hey
did you get his uh did he get his number
so it's the first lead of the day we've
got a deal no we haven't
no we haven't this is the host that's
going to make us
give him uh give him a call i work here
at coffee essence
in belfast and we were lucky today
receiving our friend sam
who is searching for new properties to
sell luckily we have some
friends of ours who will be very
happy to hear of them because they are
in the position of selling their house
at the moment
we will pass on this information to sam
and his friends and hopefully they get
in touch
so you'll get to see the results
hopefully they get to get some more
properties
get to sell them and make somebody happy
with the results
right good luck to them good luck sam
great great job you have
think a thumbs up to you bye-bye i
believe in my car
he says we've got a deal the only deal
you just got was a coffee that's the
deal
well it's just cool you need to take
fast at
massive action um offers around
89.950 on that one okay
uh can we maybe get a funeral now today
because yeah do you know what we can do
if you've got another you say you got
two properties
yeah i can see there are maybe 12
o'clock all right
great so we'll go view that house now
yeah and then while we're on the way
i'll find more houses and i'll keep
calling agents
let's go it's like taking candy off a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
unfortunately we can't arrange any other
viewings at this time or accept any
other offers
we're just looking to see if you've got
any investment properties that would
maybe fill our criteria
like flip properties
[Music]
anywhere at all in belfast as long as
the figures stack up we can move quick
on it we're looking to buy a property uh
refurbished uh for a flip would be worth
about 190
so there's 40 grand profit in it yeah
to show the affection definitely needs a
refurb
yeah yeah no that's good listen every
property we see what i think we should
offer on yeah
it's just a case of whether they say yes
i think we should go i don't know this
house
we then spent the entire day in belfast
frantically viewing properties
negotiating hard with estate agents and
we did manage to bag ourselves a few
below market value property investments
there's a lot of things that can cost a
lot of money is dampness
so dampness on average is a hundred
pounder square meter to chip it
seal it and re-plaster but if you've got
one of these here
for like 20 pounds it like could save
thousands of pounds so basically what
you do
is put it up to the plaster i was
actually really impressed with david's
construction knowledge on knowing how
much things would cost
to fix up and also his local knowledge
of the area
he knew every street in sight which
really
really
helped it'll be worth it once it was
done up i just think that um
number 150 maybe 160 165
definitely a project are you go are you
leaving this down to the next property
then
yeah i'll follow you i'll follow you up
well he was a nice guy wasn't he very
helpful i just got a message when he
wasn't there she was probably another
agent hello in 10 minutes
have we really oh my goodness i thought
that was cobwebs i felt that i thought
oh those cobwebs but now
it's just a very strange light when we
got back to the hotel i'd booked david
onto a virtual property networking event
and told him he needed to do a 20-second
pitch to try and sell the deals that
he'd found so
on this 22nd pitch dad are you feeling
nervous yeah this is probably the
hardest thing
really yeah because i've never done a
meeting ever so
did you speak for 20 seconds each side
give me 20 seconds i have no idea just
just just
try 20 seconds go uh
i honestly don't know uh it would just
it doesn't matter if you get it wrong
i would just say hello my name is david
i'm a proper investor i'm an actor in
belfast city
this week i found some juicy properties
and
if anyone's interested in properties uh
can you reach out to me isn't that
perfect
yeah this is actually my first meeting
acting from danny goldberg i'm actually
in belfast this weekend
looking at property i think we'll be
shared with you anywhere in
any way in the box this is [ __ ]
tier two hours like i'm on here trying
to sell a deal but i don't think that's
gonna happen tonight
david was getting frustrated with his
lack of attention span
saying that there weren't opportunities
for him to sell the deals
i just don't think he was really trying
hard enough um
it's boring samuel says you might be
able to sell a deal tonight but
you can't even network because
do you know what to look for in a
business partner
anybody else who else is and we've got
time for some more
oh about protections did i see somebody
else waving at me before i saw ryan
darren were you waving at me
right uh ryan
david david echoes i can see you
gesticulating at
me hello
yes welcome thank you uh my name is
david eckles i'm a property investor and
a property deal sorter
so this week i've been in belfast and
i've actually found quite a few
good deals for investors i buy
refurbished finance
so if anyone wants to get in touch with
me
you know about my deals or if i could
help anybody in any way about investing
in an ordinary and just please get in
touch and
drop me a message and if i can help
people
he will never sell those deals unless he
changes his attitude
i couldn't even be in the frigging room
oh
we spent so long finding these deals
we've got more properties to look at
tomorrow
and he's not even being grateful for the
fact that i found in this networking
event
he's just moaning about it
goodness right let's go
the following morning david hadn't sold
any deals as predicted
however i had booked him another
networking event tonight
so he needs to really bring his a-game
in the meantime let's find some more
houses
yeah good thanks
[Music]
that's really nice juicy juicy
juicy deal the planning is the big one
but here's what's really exciting
some of the deals we looked at yesterday
were nice they were only going to bring
us a two grand fee
this could bring us a five grand fee i
think yeah just come back to me there
this morning
and they'd be happy to accept the one
one two
okay well thank you very much if we just
put the house back
so the front of the house here you have
a car front of the house here
yes car parking space here okay
and then there's plenty long enough we
were now carrying out due diligence on
some of the deals that we found
yesterday
finding more deals and speaking to our
architects builders and planning
consultants to make sure that the deals
really were good deals before we sold
them
dave is here probably here yet build
literally right up as close to this wall
as we can get it there's no windows
no so should get should get planted
because
i've done it before when you tried to
pitch to investors yesterday
you didn't go that well did it not
really heard what did it go well number
one there wasn't enough people on the
call
yeah which isn't your fault number two
you were only allowed 20 seconds to
pitch
which wasn't your fault and number three
you sucked but now wasn't the time to
say that
so here's what i'm gonna do tonight i'm
going to arrange
another call with some of my investors
i'll have about 100 people on the call
and you'll have five minutes to pitch
okay
so you need to practice what you're
going to say
so i'm going to give you half an hour to
prepare
what your picture is going to be i want
you to do get everything ready
dude diligence on the properties all the
points the numbers
so when they say things like what about
just the property
how much is it you don't go i think it
was about it's like bang bang bang
everything's clear in your mind
yeah i'll give you half an hour so to
get prepared and then i'll have a look
at what you got
okay
how's it going
okay i know my figures but pitching to
me is not my strong point but
i want to get one chance
you're gonna sell some deals as a result
of this
you're gonna get bombarded bombarded but
just have fun
yeah remember to think of the irish
music
what is it
okay
you know what northern ireland is
actually a brilliant place to invest
i know the area inside out and all the
agents you know they're very open to
strategies
and we're actually refusing properties
that they end up so
all these deals are profitable they're
cheap
and the rental demand is so so high so
if anyone wants to buy a deal
they will sell faster just i'll leave my
details in the comments can you tell us
a bit more about the hmo
we negotiate it for 80 thousand pound uh
it can be turned into a four bed hmo
and the rental achievement is 1450 a
month
can we give a hand for david my man
david from ireland give him a hand
thank you this is david from ireland
but listen you know you can you can talk
about your deals on here
you can plug your businesses in the chat
on this group you know you can book
mentoring calls with us 24 7. we love
you
we appreciate you my heart is for every
single person to win
i want david to win if you're interested
in the deals drop him a message i know
mark palmer probably buy one he buys
everything
um look he's the king of property look
at him but guys
thank you for your time tonight we
appreciate you uh i hope you managed to
do some business with david i hope you
managed to do some business with one
another
and i hope to be able to continue
assisting you to go to the next level in
property to financial freedom all right
guys love you lots god bless see you
soon good night
good night good night
how did that compare to yesterday's call
um
what's your phone man i bet your phone's
gonna stop pinging me i i
i actually heard a message called
i've actually got a message yeah last
day taylor
yeah can you give me a call
but often go start making some right off
you guys stop making some calls you're
going to blow up now
voice notes
[Music]
thank you very much your time on 365
call today
you're well known well we have 200
people on the call
oh my god actually are you irish people
too they're really interested you know
on deals
is it just to do first come first served
yeah yeah you just sell it to whoever
paid you the money first everyone's
gonna keep asking which deal were you
most interested in and when's a good
time to talk when they're when they're
interested say what court you are about
that property
what's your situation are you ready to
go ask
leave me questions to them yeah and then
say what do you need from me to make a
decision
tell them about the deal tell them it's
your first time tell me you don't know
what you're doing
i've never done a deal before ever do
you know what
that's a good thing because i'm gonna go
to town on you making sure you're happy
because it's my first deal so what do
you need to know from me to make a
decision
oh you need to know about this this and
this okay here's the answers blah blah
how does that sound it sounds good
great my fee is 2 000 pounds does that
sound okay with you
awesome i'll send you an invoice over
you can send over the money
and then we'll hold your hand and work
with you to complete on the deal
i'll get you the teasing season over
with the invoice is there anything else
you need to know from me right now
wonderful message every single person
that calls you
have you text me your email i'll get the
terms and conditions sent over maybe
within
30 minutes and uh yeah
okay bye-bye
that's somebody looking to buy hmo and
dairy
go on some guys around me and
he's just sent him over t's and c's for
the hits and more cool
for two and a half thousand great yeah
the money did come in the bank early
hours of the morning which meant we
finally could go and pick up the keys to
david's first
rent to rent all of them
that's it thank you keys there i'll send
mine here
congrats david thank you very much you
first rank to rent yeah
you took back with as it happens the
best agent in there
it's actually quite a tidy little house
this yeah how do you feel to be the
controller of this problem
i think i'm still in shock this big
relief basically off my shoulders
this is nice isn't it it's actually
nicer that i remember seeing it when we
came on the viewing that's quite a big
bathroom too it is
this is nice not really happening this
is actually city center too
so it is city center i really like
dairy now i'm um you know i'm becoming a
fan of dairy what the size of these
rooms you could
i think i think we need to market this
now now it's your property
650 a month rent that is so cheap
considering it's a five bed
hmo property with a license city center
right beside the college too so
i actually think you got a brilliant
team oh mate the views
are absolutely gorgeous who would have
known that a renter rent would work
right on your home turf i don't know
what
so so happy samuel i can't believe how
far
you know came in a week to actually get
keys so properly why not
i'm a bit overwhelmed at the minute but
you're feeling great
what do you think you go from was i i
don't know
you're doing really well man thank you
i'm proud of you your first mentor
what you thinking i don't know
it's all right that's nice no it's just
actually got the keys to it you know
so close to home family we can move home
yeah
so this will make you what five six
hundred pound a month one more
yeah and then you can rent your own
place
[Music]
i could live in this house i would like
to live here actually
it's you'd like to live here yeah this
is cheaper than when i rent in the uk
and of a whole house 6.50 but how you
going to afford to pay i thought this
was going to be a rent to rent and why
do you need
i actually got a whole house close to
home you want to rent the whole house
you want to live in the whole thing i
like to live here yeah
okay sorry
i don't understand i don't i do they go
to rent to rent
around today's really nice area samuel
this is like
it is nice but but but
you mean living in one of the rooms and
when the other rooms out or you mean you
want to rent the whole thing
you know if i did live in here i could
rent out the rooms and actually make
make a nice profit per month i i'm not
going to be fully financially free but
you know it's still an income and i can
actually move home
you lived in one of these rooms and you
rented out the other rooms
it's i don't think it's a great i'm not
sure it's a great idea i don't know if
you're just like emotionally wrapped up
in it
i think so yeah got a bit overwhelmed i
mean
if the option's there or you could just
go get another rent to rent
i did i'd like to i delonged down the
line someone would like to build my own
house so
it's cheap properties here cheap to
build yeah i think you can do that
it's so so cheap you know that how about
your uncle's land
because i've not seen this yet but i've
got that for free your uncle's land i'm
gonna get that for free and
all my family's on the trade so so your
uncle is happy for you to have the land
yeah and then you'll build on it i can
build a really really cheap samuel and
that's got perfect views really nice
area
that's a long term plan yeah okay so
right now why don't we do this
why don't we get this place on airbnb
get some short stay get some money
coming in yeah
sell some those two deals that we've not
sold yet we've sold one deal
sell the other two deals with the tutors
we've got fingers crossed we'll sell
them
get some money coming in from this and
from deal selling yes
and then when we've done that we'll meet
your uncle and we'll start putting some
plans together on the line i want to
show you it's really really i'm excited
it's so nice
oh dude i'm really excited i can't
believe how fast this is coming together
and i
love island do you want to go look at
this the land
yeah 30 minutes away so
i don't know if we should just sell the
deals and get this on airbnb first let's
just sell the deals and not get
distracted or ahead of ourselves let's
sell the deals
get the money then put this on airbnb
tonight go look at the land tomorrow yes
brilliant all right let's go
this won't make money unless it's rented
out let's get this bad boy rented out
so david was really happy with his first
rent to rent property
and his new deal packaging business was
proving successful
as property investors were queuing up to
pay him thousands of pounds
do you see that house up there on the
left
yeah that's our house that's the house
we secured
look at the view oh do you like it i
love it invest it for you
yeah yeah it looks like it should come
through anyways
yeah i'm gonna fly back there on sunday
and then i'm gonna look at the house on
monday
this is really it's really great
appreciate your support bye-bye
yes there's money in the bank what just
happened is
david just made two thousand pounds and
it's just for a lot of people that's
like a month salary
you know and david just made it just
like that it's fine i'll get you
everything over on an email and dave can
send you over the invoice for one
nine nine five fantastic i'm looking
forward to that
excellent thanks so much bye bye bye
yes yes so so far from scratch we've
made
thousands and thousands of pounds
packaging up property investment deals
and passing them on to investors for a
fee david got the keys
to his very own rent to rent property
but we weren't done yet because david
wanted to find his dream home before i
went back to england
stay tuned for part three